this is good for when you drive driving
with one hand eating your burrito with
the other no we eat pizza in LA we just
put salad on it
that works that works
it's like salad and breadsticks had a
baby and then formed a pizza because it
doesn't really taste like pizza it
tastes more like salad and bread
we're in downtown LA at Robin Hood where
I'm about to eat a vegan ramen with a
vegan egg as in laid by a Topher boot
not a chicken so the white part is made
of soy milk
and the yellow part is nutritional yeast
I guess you can't poke the yolk to have
it spill out after the ramen part
the important part to ramen is obviously
the noodles but more importantly is the
broth
oh yeah
here's delicious hot dog it's a carrot
Oh a hot dog made from carrots
see underneath all the brussel sprouts
that's a carrot
okay going to do the side bite it tastes
like the carrots that would be at the
bottom of a stew something that's been
cooked for a really long time does not
taste like a hot dog at all but it's a
fun way to eat your vegetables where it
Kai's in Santa Monica where I just got a
sushi burrito
let's go to the car I need it look at
this thing
behold the sushi burrito it's everything
that you would find in a burrito except
in a nori wrapper
there's pinto beans and corn and
tortilla chips if you don't like seaweed
you're not going to like this but it's
really delicious tastes exactly like a
burrito except without a flour tortilla
thumbs up so this is organic ice cream
very important that it's organic has
raspberry sauce it has chocolate
crumbles chocolate shavings and on top
salted caramel cotton candy I don't even
know how to eat this my mouth doesn't
know what to make up this much sugar
like everything my mom told me not to do
in one bite so if I had to crown the
most la food for this video I think it
would probably have to be the sushi
burrito just because at least I'm for
sushi and at least known for burritos
and
so perfect Misha plus it was gluten-free
and vegan and all that other stuff